digamos que somos una compañía
farmacéutica y desarrollamos un
medicamento que creemos va a ayudar a
las personas con diabetes en particular
creemos que va a ayudar a reducir el
nivel de hemoglobina a1c y para aquellos
de ustedes que no estén familiarizados
con lo que es la hemoglobina a1c los
invito a que vean los vídeos que tenemos
al respecto en khan academy pero la idea
general es que si se tienen niveles
altos de azúcar en la sangre durante
aproximadamente un periodo de tres meses
un promedio alto de niveles de azúcar en
la sangre tendremos un valor alto de a1c
y si tenemos un promedio bajo de azúcar
en la sangre durante un periodo de tres
meses aproximadamente tendremos un valor
bajo de hemoglobina a1c así que si el
tomar la medicina hace que estos niveles
de h1 se bajen en las personas que la
tomen más de lo que resultaría de un
proceso aleatorio o debido a otras
variables pues sería un indicador de que
esta medicina podría ser efectiva para
ayudar a controlar la
de estas personas aquí vamos a construir
un experimento para probar esto vamos a
decir que ya sea que se tome esta
medicina o no esta será mi variable
explicativa y lo que nosotros queremos
que responda a esto en este caso los
niveles de a1c son nuestro indicador de
que se está ayudando a controlar los
niveles de azúcar a esto le vamos a
llamar la variable explicada cómo vamos
a realizar este experimento digamos que
tenemos un grupo de personas 100
personas que necesitan controlar su
diabetes y decimos bueno vamos a tomar
la mitad de este grupo y los pondremos
en un grupo de tratamiento la otra mitad
la pondremos en un grupo de control y
veremos si el grupo de tratamiento
mejora sus niveles de hemoglobina a1c de
una manera que se note que no es
aleatoria vamos a hacerlo obtendremos un
grupo de control y tendremos el grupo de
tratamiento y podríamos decir bueno pues
al grupo del tratamiento le damos la
medicina que creamos y al grupo de
control no le damos nada pero
esto podría introducir un aspecto
psicológico en el que quizá el beneficio
de tomar la medicina sea que la gente
diga bueno estoy tomando una medicina
que me va a ayudar a controlar mi
diabetes y psicológicamente de cierta
manera les afecta en los niveles de
azúcar en la sangre que de hecho es algo
posible quizá los inspire a comportarse
de una manera más saludable y digan
bueno estoy tomando una medicina que me
ayuda a controlar mi diabetes así que
pues puedo comer más cosas que no
debería y la medicina lo va a controlar
así que para evitar el hecho de que el
suelo pensar que se está tomando una
medicina para controlar esto afecta el
comportamiento de las personas lo que
queremos hacer es dar a ambos grupos una
medicina y lo vamos a hacer de manera
que ninguno de los grupos se dé cuenta
de cuál medicina están recibiendo lo que
vamos a hacer es que a este grupo le
vamos a dar un placebo y este grupo
recibirá la medicina real pero ambas
deben lucir igual y las personas no
deben saber en qué grupo se encuentran
cuando hacemos esto le llamamos
experimento ciego
hayan escuchado de experimentos doble
ciego y ese es el caso en el que no solo
las personas no saben en qué grupos se
encuentran sino que incluso las personas
que están administrando las medicinas no
saben cuáles están administrando así que
digamos que queremos hacer esto un
experimento doble ciego de manera que
incluso la persona que está dando la
medicina no sabe cuál está dando y
ustedes se podrían preguntar por qué es
importante esto bueno es posible que
inconscientemente las personas que
administran la medicina a los pacientes
podrían dar pistas de alguna manera de
que se esté dando la medicina o el
placebo quizá no hagan el énfasis
suficiente en la importancia de los
horarios en los que se debe tomar la
medicina si supieran que está fuera del
placebo así que para evitar que este
tipo de cosas ocurran tenemos los
experimentos doble ciego a veces incluso
se habla de experimentos triple ciego en
donde las personas que analizan la
información tampoco saben cuáles son del
grupo de control y cuáles son del grupo
de tratamiento
es otra forma de evitar el sesgo ahora
que ya sabemos cómo vamos a hacer
nuestro experimento tenemos nuestro
grupo de control nuestro grupo de
tratamiento tenemos aún no sé cómo
nuestra variable explicada por lo que
vamos a medir el nivel de hemoglobina
a1c en las personas de estos grupos
vamos a hacerlo antes de que reciban la
medicina o el placebo y después de quizá
tres meses volveremos a medir estos
niveles de hemoglobina a1c pero la
siguiente pregunta es cómo vamos a
dividir a estas 100 personas en estos
dos grupos y podrían decir pues vamos a
hacerlo aleatoriamente lo cual está muy
bien ya que si no lo hacen de esta forma
y ponen por ejemplo a todos los hombres
en un grupo y a todas las mujeres en
otro grupo
podríamos tener error debido a las
características de cada sexo que puede
influenciar nuestros resultados de los
niveles de esta variable y esto puede
ocurrir si medimos los niveles de un
grupo de personas similares personas de
la misma edad o de una misma zona
geográfica con cierto tipo de hábitos de
alimentación no queremos esto para
evitar tener un desequilibrio aquí
debido a variables ocultas que puedan
confort
nos vamos a buscar tener muestras
aleatorias y tenemos varios vídeos que
hablan sobre formas de tener muestras
aleatorias así que vamos a tener
muestras aleatorias que vamos a poner en
ambos grupos una forma muy sencilla de
hacerlo es asignar a cada una de las
personas de aquí un número del 1 al 100
usar un generador de números aleatorios
entre el 1 y el 100 para elegir a 50
personas que poner ya sea en el grupo de
control o en el grupo de tratamiento
ahora si hacemos una asignación
totalmente aleatoria podríamos tener una
situación en la que tengamos una
proporción mayor de hombres en un grupo
que en otro o viceversa y para evitar
esto queremos algo de muestreo
estratificado como vimos en otro vídeo
que es lo que llamamos diseño de bloques
para nuestra asignación aleatoria en
donde dividimos este grupo entre hombres
y mujeres no sé quizá en este ejemplo
tenemos 60 mujeres y 40 hombres y lo que
hacemos aquí es elegir aleatoriamente
dentro de estas 60 mujeres 30 que van a
ir al grupo de control y otras 30 que
van a ir en el grupo d
tratamiento y vamos a elegir
aleatoriamente 20 de los 40 hombres para
poner en uno de los grupos ya sea el de
control o de tratamiento y los otros 20
hombres que quedan en el otro grupo y de
esta manera el sexo que nos introduzca
sesgo aquí así que esto que hicimos aquí
es el diseño de bloques que es realmente
una versión del muestreo estratificado y
quizás haya otras variables ocultas que
nos puedan confundir aquí y que quizá
aquí no se muestren aleatoriamente así
que hay otras formas de asignar
aleatoriamente para evitar esto y una
vez que hacemos esto después de tres
meses veremos cuál es el cambio en los
niveles de hemoglobina a1c si vemos que
no hay diferencia entre estos dos grupos
en los niveles de a1c podríamos decir
que hay una gran probabilidad de que
esta medicina no haga nada y nuevamente
todo esto trata de probabilidades hay
cierta probabilidad de que simplemente
hayamos tenido mala suerte aunque quizás
sea una probabilidad muy pequeña si es
que hacemos esto con una buena cantidad
de personas y por eso queremos mejorar
nuestra comprensión sobre estadística
cuáles son los umbrales que pensamos
tienen alta
y dado baja probabilidad para que
nosotros nos sentamos cómodos con
nuestros descubrimientos pero digamos
que si vemos un cambio una mejora y
necesitamos pensar esta mejora pudo
haber ocurrido debido al azar o es muy
poco probable que esto haya pasado
simplemente al azar y si es muy poco
probable que esto haya ocurrido al azar
pueden sentirse bastante bien lo mismo
que otras personas que le dan sus
resultados acerca de esta medicina aún
así la ciencia no termina aquí nadie
puede decir que está 100% seguro de que
esta medicina funciona ya que puede
haber variables que no hayamos detectado
en nuestro experimento aún cuando
hayamos hecho este diseño de bloques
podríamos aleatoriamente tener una
cantidad desproporcionada de personas
mayores en un grupo que en el otro grupo
o de personas de cierto lugar geográfico
en un grupo o en el otro siempre hay
cosas que considerar y lo más importante
a considerar es que aunque hagamos esto
lo mejor que podamos podemos tener la
probabilidad de que alguien haya tenido
un falso positivo o hubiéramos tenido
estos buenos resultado
al azar o alguien haya tenido un falso
negativo así que una idea muy importante
en los experimentos y en la ciencia en
general es que este experimento debemos
de documentarlo de manera de que pueda
ser replicado con la esperanza de que
obtengan resultados consistentes así que
no son solamente los resultados es el
diseño del experimento de manera que
otras personas puedan y deban replicarlo
y mostrar así que estos resultados son
válidos que no son aleatorios o debidos
a una mala administración de este
experimento